violence against women and domestic  violence are not a private matter  they are a societal problem  every single victim is one victim too  many there is no tradition no culture no  love no honor no clothing no behavior  and no excuse that can never justify  violence yet  it happens at work at schools in the  streets in alleyways in parking lots and  online  too  there is no safe space  and it can happen to anyone  all spaces should be safe  if you are a victim of violence or know  someone who is report this crime  together we can prevent violence protect  women and girls and bring perpetrators  to justice  today the european commission adopts a  proposal for a directive combating  violence against women and domestic  violence  [Music]  you